ils ont pris leur service comme
d'habitude parce qu'ils sont de ce bois
qu'on n'entame pas facilement
pourtant le coeur n'y est plus vraiment
le couperet est tombé hier l'entreprise
vit ses dernières semaines est
complètement brutal pour nous faire
attendre et pas du tout
la prod investissement humain dans
trackmania prod y avait trop de coeur et
le coup est d'autant plus brutal que le
groupe venait d'investir plus de 15
millions d'euros dans l'outil de travail
une trancheuse de compétition une usine
biomasse est une erreur tout miser ou
presque sur le marché du parquet qui
s'écroulent les premières l'âme
à peine sorti des ateliers et comme si
cela ne suffisait pas l'entreprise subit
la guerre des label éco durable celui
que pratique l'europe de l'ouest n'est
pas du goût d'un certain géant suédois
qui fait la pluie et le beau temps
lobbying des certifications nous empêche
d'avoir une alternative est de pouvoir
basculer sur une production standard
notre coeur de métier à l'origine de
l'entreprise dans les années en fin des
années 60
un effet ciseau redoutable qui tue le
chiffre d'affaires et fait tomber 98
tête
pour nous il n'y a plus d'alternative
perdre le site là et continue de
produire en tchéquie
ça fait du mal à le comprendre on a
beaucoup de mal à comprendre dans
l'industrie du bois est une industrie
familiale quelle que soit la taille de
l'entreprise et je dirais que mes
collègues voilà c'est une journée
psychologiquement et des temps très
difficile psychologiquement c'est moi
qu'on puisse dire
le processus de la cessation d'activité
est enclenché la fermeture devrait être
effective avant l'hiver dender france ex
jura plaquage ne fabriquera pas sa
planche de salut